[Aplausos]
boa tarde a todos e hoje venho falarmos
sobre isso podem ver na imagem e o meu
objetivo é principalmente fazer uma
reflexão sobre a forma inspirar em você
esperamos fazer um desafio é
relativamente pequena com cerca de 158
mil habitantes a china fez muitas
amizades creme empresa também aqui mais
uma agência de marketing e aprendi muito
ao longo destes anos
nesse momento eu trabalho numa empresa
chamada prova que é uma empresa que
vende aumentar se tenho o meu carro lá é
a direção do marketing
já trabalho há já alguns anos nesta área
quando posso aprender muito sobre
negócios em geral não é
e também aprendemos o mar tem sobre o
desenvolvimento de marcas
desenvolvimento de produtos sobre vendas
principalmente sobre nossas online isso
como disse temos cerca de 150 mil
habitantes
e essas pessoas trabalham
maioritariamente nas mais de 6 mil
empresas que existem cá e eu queria
fazer aqui uma pergunta quem é que ele
merece todo o problema não é muita gente
e já que falamos de negócios quem é que
vocês conheçam alguém que tem uma
empresa e que conhece alguém que tenha
negócios online
a loja não reconhece que são menos
alguns de vocês faça já fez uma vez
então
se vocês fazem compras online
provavelmente devem conhecer uma das
maiores lojas do mundo que é conhecido
por todos que ninguém pode dizer que o
loja mais popular no mundo inteiro
a maior loja do mundo a loja depois
chinês foi fundada há 22 anos mais ou
menos em 1984 numa pequena cidade
chamada bellview quem vender livros na
internet hoje em dia nós vamos vender
tudo e mais alguma coisa
o shopping online nós podemos comprar
eletrodomésticos livros roupa e amazônia
uma das mais lojas no mundo quer dizer
que a amazônia não só vendo os seus
próprios produtos mas também permite que
os vendedores e que outras empresas
também quer dizer que se eu oi por
exemplo uma empresa que eu posso me
enviando todo mundo podem vender os
produtos ganham uma comissão só ter uma
idéia hoje em dia existem mais dois
milhões do vendedor de roteiristas que
vendem na plataforma da amazônia
qualquer coisa 2 milhões de empresas e
dos turistas que vêm para mais de 300
milhões
os ativos que fazem compras na zona mais
de 300 mil professores ativos e qualquer
coisa e um volume de negócios anual
neste momento o melhor em 2005 em dois
mil e quinhentos foi de cerca de 107
milhões de dólars a perguntar pra mim
está então a ver com isso e vamos ver
porque vamos contar uma história uma
história muito uma empresa de braga numa
pequena lojinha vagas ficaram no 1 a 1
em um milhão se eo autor de 23 anos
apenas um jovem com 23 anos que teve uma
idéia de criar por uma loja que vendia
produtos biológicos produtos orgânicos
alimentação saudável
há dez anos era uma grande loucura ou
seja quase ninguém sabe o que é isso
os produtos vêm ter comigo e bem só vai
precisar da sua ajuda para ajudar o país
a funcionar não ajudaram a montar a
minha loja criando enquanto marta em
fazer por ser a minha imagem
esse foi o melhor a fazer hoje ela abriu
sua loja em trabalhou 30 durante alguns
meses e mesmo por mês mais ou menos um
ano
a loja show basicamente não funcionava
provavelmente este seria o nosso para
este momento estava numa via lá à frente
do seu tempo e não estavam preparados
para isso
mas como tudo na vida há sempre uma
aprendizagem e surgem sempre novas e
assim foi
neste caso a história que existia uma
pequena proteína aqui na loja que na
altura se chamava uma pequena prateleira
vendia suplementos alimentares
e que vende mais que eu já tô estamos a
falar de uma loja que júpiter cerca de
200 metros quadrados mais ou menos e uma
pequena prateleira vendia mais que a
loja toda e qualquer coisa de
extraordinário é que se passa aqui que é
possível que havia um mercado havia um
nicho que procurava os produtos então
encheu se de coragem e sem nenhum tinha
newton na loja sem nenhum pensou ok eu
tenho aqui uma pena mas eu preciso de
vocês não podem é preciso uma estratégia
e foi o que pensou então é preciso três
coisas eu preciso de dinheiro para fazer
o investimento e fazer cheiro negócio a
negócio funciona
preciso de ter muita contenção nas
minhas despesas fixas na minha volta a
este ponto seja fato ter uma loja foto
ter empregados ter uma série de despesas
fixas que uma loja é correta ou mais
aceitação não vende o suficiente para
conseguir pagar as despesas
então com um pouco com um pouco e
precisava de uma outra coisa também que
era o que era precisamente clientes vão
precisar do máximo de pontos possível
para poder fazer o seu negócio
então foi que eu decidiu fazer uma coisa
bastante arriscada
miguel rosa que menos vendeu tudo o que
tinha pra começar este negócio há quem
prefira o carro miguel pelo menos um
carro semelhante que o vendeu para poder
montar o seu negócio ou seja é tudo tudo
o que tinha para montar o nosso a seguir
a ter falhado um digamos assim
e foi aqui precisa muito vencer a prova
neste momento em que todo nutrição
esportiva na suplementação alimentar meu
melhor enquanto muitas vezes uma
história de vida que quando abriu a sua
loja ainda com muitas dúvidas
começava a receber as encomendas uma um
dia após dia eu quase nem queria
acreditar que estava sob encomenda da
internet
naquela altura era algo
é muito raro digamos assim enquanto aqui
é uma uma encomenda encomenda de calções
e chinelos aos ctt entre elas ou
encomenda serra lá entregar a encomenda
em e ela pode escolher se quer alguma
coisa a gente empatar quatro a dez anos
atrás e hoje em dia já não é um milhão
que envia as encomendas hoje em dia nós
temos uma equipe de dezenas de pessoas
falam em pequim eo embalamento das
encomendas que tem mais de 15 mil metros
quadrados que envia milhares de
encomendas para todo mundo
nós não vemos mais nada além disso
já não é um milhão que leva ao ct é só o
gtt que venha até a nossa empresa até o
nosso armazém fica aqui na prova e que
chegam carrinhos encaminhou emendas do
mundo online em em todo mundo
um dos líderes mundiais do segmento
alimentar ou mais ou menos anos atrás e
tem sido no mínimo uma experiência muito
interessante renovados apenas nós
conseguimos por exemplo neste momento
enviar mais de quatro mil encomendas
diárias para mais de 100 países
nós temos neste momento mais de um
milhão de clientes registados na nossa
loja e mais 5 mil referências de
produtos que estão constantemente em
estoque disponível na nossa loja online
agora quem é que conheça provas está no
ar uma facturação prevista de mais de 50
milhões de anos tanto jogo posso afirmar
que é um sucesso em apenas 9 anos temos
conseguido atingir o sucesso tendo
muitos dos nossos 250 colaboradores
quando eu conheci união era apenas eu ea
esposa de helton
somos mais de 250 trabalhadores e como é
que foi possível com o trabalho em
equipe esta gente toda a atingir esse
sucesso que atingiu então o que é que
isso tem a ver com guimarães mais uma
vez que o fundo eu eu digo então eu vou
voltar atrás nunca lembrar que no início
mas também falou em uma pequena cidade
chamada brasil tenha apenas 133 mil
habitantes do mundo e uma das melhores
do mundo
a paz que tem produtos de vocês estão
aqui que são paulo
o desafio é criar todo mundo
isto foi muito dinheiro mas nós aqui em
braga e guimarães que fizemos
não é o vil metal mas vamos é qualquer
coisa de extraordinário e há poucos anos
atrás abriu aqui uma parca uma
plataforma um marco pois também brutal
que se chama farfetch farfetch conseguiu
ser um dos maiores marcas do país do
mundo
então isso é possível mas amigos eu acho
que tem mesmo possível e é bom a
proposta é não estarmos todos para
criarmos um novo empresarial uma
plataforma de vendas online baseada em
uma forte plataforma logística e
obviamente nós temos um show em serviço
e entregar os atletas não isto não
funciona
desenvolvida por uma equipa do
ex-portista e acreditem que nós temos
aqui porque está bem demais e eu posso
ter um deus por exemplo e isso é
possível nós fazemos um ovo empresarial
desenvolveu todo esse projeto e
primitiva que as empresas guimarães e e
os empresários de lojas etc
façam venda para todo mundo para milhões
de consumidores
enquanto tivermos a nossa idéia é manter
a nossa cozinha nossa empresa aqui a
vender 150 200 mil pessoas eventualmente
tiverem turistas mais um pouco
queremos dizem que nós abriremos um mark
após o nós vendemos os produtos de
mulheres
toda a gente colabora onde toda a gente
pode usar o que pode acontecer o que
pode acontecer sem não vamos a própria
defesa
imagine daqui a dez anos e eu gostaria
estar aqui é daqui a dez anos veja o
resultado
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]